hey guys dr. Burke here listen in this video I'm
gonna discuss how to dissolve kidney stones but I
want to make a disclaimer first make sure that
you're discussing it for this information any
changes with your doctor because this is not meant
for a replacement for any meds or any surgery that
they're gonna do any okay so I just wanted to
present this as extra information to work with
he or she in helping to you know prevent this from
coming back or helping slow down stones sometimes
it takes several months to dissolve stones and
if you can prevent an invasive procedure I think
it's worth it to try this you can always go
back and get your ultrasound and see if the
stones are shrinking but here's here's the data
most kidney stones are calcium oxalate stones
or calcium phosphate stones twenty percent or
a little less than twenty percent of the stones
are uric acid crystal stones okay so there's two
different there's several but these are the main
two now golf stones are completely different than
kidney stones as far as the formation gall stones
are more cholesterol stones because of lack of
bile kidney stones if we're going to talk about
the most common are calcium oxalate stones okay so
there's there's really two things that you need to
put your attention on one is removing the oxalates
from your diet this is like a waste product from
metabolism but oxalates bind with calcium in the
kidney okay and they develop these little crystals
that then can create a lot of problems they can
get lodged right on the kidney right before the
ureter and cause a backup of fluid and pressure
and cause a lot of pain the symptoms from kidney
stones are very similar to the symptoms from gull
stones so sometimes you don't know what is causing
what because they're very very similar but you
can get an ultrasound or a cat scan to find that
out all right so the underlying mechanism is that
usually the person is low in citrates and high
in oxalates now citrates actually help prevent
the formation of stones and help dissolve stones
so the two mechanisms that you want to focus
our increasing sit rates in the diet decreasing
oxalates all right so let's go through step one
number one you want to increase sit rates there
are many types of lemon juice that you can
consume I like the volcano lemon juice you
can even get lemon juice any lemon juice and it
will work but I would like to recommend that you
get a higher quality lemon juice because it's
a lot more nutritious volcano is the best but
you can just get organic lemon juice but lemon
juice has a lot of citrates anything any mineral
with citrate at the end of it is a citrate so
you can do potassium citrate which I like that
one way better than sodium citrate but potassium
citrate will break off so a good portion of the
potassium will go this way the citrate will
go that way and it starts to form with the
calcium and help break up the stones so that will
handle the citrate number two you want to avoid
oxalates now I put a link down below of all the
different categories of foods and what has high
extremely high oxalates and what are very low
and you can use that but spinach is the top of
the list spinach has hundreds of milligrams of
oxalates per ounces of spinach and then we also
have avocado is high dates are high grapefruit
is high potato wheat beans beets are very high
Swiss chard is very high Kiwi canned pineapple is
very high figs and tofu are very high in oxalates
okay nuts unfortunately very high almonds are
very very high I'm sorry did you realize that
kale is very low in oxalates even though it's a
cruciferous it has like seven teen milligrams
per three ounces spinach is hundreds okay cabbage
is low in oxalates bok choy is low cauliflower is
low cucumber is low so take the list down below
dissect it make notes and what you're going to
you know do if as far as you're changing your
diet now the point I want to make is this it is
true and some of the other videos I talked about
calcium coming out of solution into the different
soft tissues when your body is too alkaline okay
so when you have alkalosis calcium participates or
it precipitates out of the solution and starts
clogging up joints and things that's true but
if you take dietary calcium like some cheese
and things like that that will not end up in
the calcium through the kidneys in fact some of
that calcium through the digestive system will
bind with the oxalates and lower the chance of
getting a stone the thing you need to worry about
is taking dietary extra calcium like supplements
like calcium in a supplement form especially
calcium carbonate you want to avoid that so just
make sure you're not taking these supplements
with calcium but you can take some dietary foods
that are higher in calcium okay the other point I
want to make is there's a confusion with vitamin D
there's mixed reviews a lot of the recent research
says that vitamin D actually helps lower stones
some of the older research says it will increase
it but here's my viewpoint vitamin D helps the
absorption of calcium in the intestines by 20
times that doesn't necessarily mean it ends up in
the kidney okay so I think it's okay vitamin k2 is
another vitamin that's very important if you have
kidney stones because that helps you hold calcium
in the bone that helps you remove calcium from
soft tissues and puts it in the bone where it
should be so this is a very good anti kidney stone
vitamin there's also mixed reviews and vitamin C
or ascorbic acid you know synthetic like large
amounts of the scorebook acid some studies show
that it increases some studies do not so I am I
don't have an opinion about it and see I don't
know exactly what it does some people think that
cranberry helps dissolve kidney stones it does
not all cranberry will do will help lessen the
stickiness of the bacteria on your ladder okay
now let's talk about uric acid crystals now that
particular type of stone usually comes when your
pH is too acid your urine pH is too acid and that
could happen after several things number one you
need a ketosis diet and all of a sudden you upload
a kidney stone or you have an insulin problem a
lot of diabetics have kidney stones because of the
sugar involved because sugar fructose that kind of
can lead to uric acid building up in the body so
if you have more of the uric acid stones what you
want to do is increase the pH and you can do that
or alkalis the by a little bit more by taking the
potassium citrate or even lemon juice because both
of these are alkaline even though the lemon juice
is a an acid it turns into an alkaline ash in the
body so actually these two remedies will be good
for both of these the I last point on the mention
that's very very important is that if you have a
uric acid crystals in the kidney they're little
stones or gout you need to fix the insulin you
need to lower the insulin okay because it usually
comes from insulin resistance I'm gonna put a link
down below to give you the data I just wanted the
more of a comprehensive video because I have a
lot of different videos talking about different
aspects but this is a real comprehensive video
just to give you the overview of what to do if
you had a kidney stone alright thanks for watching